welcome back to cbs mornings five years
after hurricane maria hit puerto rico
the devastation caused by hurricane
fiona this week is expected to add to
the island's health care crisis about
half of the people living on the island
depend on the public health care system
but local officials say federal funding
gaps have led to staff shortages and
long wait times for patients 80 percent
of puerto rico's seniors rely on
programs like medicare advantage but
it's funded there far below the average
national rate let's head back to our
lead national correspondent david bagnon
puerto rico david what's going on with
this health care system
look my friend i want to set up what
you're about to see with this context
puerto ricans believe they are treated
like second-class citizens when you
compare the u.s citizens in the united
states so it's not just the physical
infrastructure here that is broken
mismanaged and not given the proper
funding
fair funding it's also also things like
the health care system this story came
to us from puerto ricans on the island
who said we need help making this known
if you ask all the players within the
health care system patients providers
and administrators they will all agree
maria just showed you what was happening
but the system collapsed way before then
puerto rico native nelson varus diaz is
a researcher at florida international
university
since hurricane maria five years ago
professor baras diaz has overseen
studies that assess the state of health
care on the island what caused the
collapse the collapse is caused mainly
by
debt and the economic crisis in puerto
rico and a historic privatization of the
healthcare system there our research
shows patients are waiting for six to
eight months to get an appointment with
a specialist
if that's not a sign of collapse that i
don't know what is dr edgar dominic
fagundo is an ear nose and throat
specialist in ponce on the southern part
of the island
dating back as far as 1999 he remembers
seeing about 30 patients a day the
average i see is anywhere from 50 to 60
patients a day every time i'm in the
office now he's so busy new patients
can't see him until march of next year
the day before we visited him he had
diagnosed a man with tongue cancer that
patient waited three months to see him
the longer people wait their diagnosis
gets laid and so things like cancer and
other illnesses you want to treat them
early so that patient will have a better
chance of cure dr carlos miato is the
island's health secretary i had a woman
write to me and say that her father was
having a stroke
and they couldn't find a neurosurgeon
they couldn't find one
and that's why people are also leaving
the islands i have 17. never surgery
so if you have 17 neurosurgeons
and how many people live here
3.2 billion hey siri what's 3.2 million
divided by 17
two hundred thousand divided by
seventeen is approximately one hundred
eighty eight thousand two hundred thirty
five point two nine so you have one
neurosurgeon for every one hundred and
eighty eight thousand people yeah
that's scary it is nicole damiani's 25
year old husband carlos rivera was
hospitalized about two and a half weeks
ago what happened to carlos so he sat up
on his bed and he fell onto the floor
and he was having a seizure and so i
rushed him to the hospital
and there was something on his ct scan
how many days before you saw a
neurosurgeon eight
eight days did they tell you why
well the doctors are overworked
there are many many cases patients
people that need help so
the fact that there's you know of
limited amount of practitioners
certified practitioners
available to attend the masses is pretty
alarming he had bleeding and swelling on
his brain he spoke to us from his
hospital bed in cagos puerto rico it's
really hard to find a nerdy surgeon here
in puerto rico and he got to a point
where i really
low-key gave up in life
and like it got really frustrating to a
point now one of the reasons patients
like carlos have such a hard time
getting medical care is that many puerto
rican doctors are moving to florida
because the pay is significantly better
for instance the average yearly salary
for a family physician in florida is two
hundred and twenty one thousand dollars
in puerto rico they make less than one
hundred thousand
jorge mata runs centro medico it's a
complex of hospitals in san juan he took
us to the icu to witness the impact of
low wages this is one of the empty rooms
that
if we were to have uh nurses it would be
used
as you see it's completely
ready
15 icu beds
eight of them are empty because they
don't have the nurses to work them
galia malias has been a registered nurse
at central medical for 19 years
she rides her son's bicycle to work she
says her pay is so low she can't afford
a car every 15 days you were telling me
your check is how much
eight hundred
ninety one dollars
is like a 25 cents or something like
that
that's not enough to live on for you no
that's not enough i need to move to
puerto rico
i have to learn
more english
because i have two ministers you have
two masters yeah wow and you're making
less than 900 every 15 days yeah
i love my job
i love my country but i don't see any in
this in this
country
i'm very sad for that very very sad
because my mom made me
and my son
these young men and women are the future
doctors from puerto rico and they showed
up as a group to let us know how gravely
concerned they are about the state of
health care on the island carlo bocas is
a second year medical student at the
university of puerto rico we look at the
conditions around us the things that
doctors tell us our own professors
family members that may be in medicine
we hear constantly about the problems
that are facing the island and just
within three years we might have to make
that faithful decision where we either
stay or we leave and it's not entirely
under our control show of hands who
wants to stay and work here
put your hand down if you think you
might have to leave
wow 50 50 chance you know wow it's not
up to us
boy david i see why they reached out to
you that's certainly a story that needs
to be told and now that we're also down
to know the facts what's the solution
here
well so i'm glad you asked that question
the governor is saying what we need is
more federal funding to come on a
consistent basis but he said david it's
not like we want to sound like we're
asking for more than somebody else gets
we just want the same that other people
get we want fairness he said even if you
compare us to the poorest state in the
united states mississippi they get so
much more than we do because puerto rico
is a territory and that circles back to
where i started that is why puerto
ricans will say we are treated like
second-class citizens
david thank you so much eye-opening
really puts things in perspective that's
for sure